well hey you guys thought I would just
pop in and do a little movie review like
I said I would on the show last night
because I haven't done one in a little
while and this was actually a
recommendation so I thought I wanted to
get around to it and like I said I
watched it earlier this week and it's
really good so I really did want to talk
about it before we get into that let me
give a quick shout out to our
affiliate uh sponsor kind of company
thing uh which on today's show is going
to be audible most of you probably know
what audible is uh as by Amazon and it
is a very very large maybe the world's
largest repository of uh audiob books
podcasts pretty much anything audio that
you can think of it's pretty awesome uh
I use it a lot myself so basically
there's a link down in the description
box and if you click on that link then
you will get a 30-day free trial of
audible and you may listen to anything
on their platform over that 30 days and
you also get one free credit to use
however ever you see fit and whatever
you purchase with that credit you may
keep that forever if you are already an
Amazon Prime member um I have to admit
oh come on now I think I
disconnected okay you back on all right
I'm just going to keep on
going all right so um yeah I'm actually
kind of embarrassed to admit um that I
had actually never even heard of this
movie or the book that it was based on
until somebody recommended it to me a
while back like I wrote it down and they
described it to me and I was like oh man
that sounds really good um and they were
like yeah this is probably like right up
your alley now that alley I have lots of
alleys I mean obviously anybody that
knows me but one of those alleys uh is a
very dark Cobblestone alley in Victorian
London uh with lots of gas lamps and
[__] like that uh and that's kind of the
alley that that we're talking about here
this is basic
basically uh Victorian era murder
mystery with real historical characters
like kind of woven into the narrative
right um think like somewhere in the
ballpark of maybe like from Hell or the
prestige or maybe um the book Dan
Simmons drood uh which was kind of based
around Charles Dickens and wilky Collins
but was a fictionalized story this is
kind of along those lines um also has
and I did mention from hell it does have
like a lot of like Jack the Ripper
influence as well
so this particular movie uh came out
it's a British film it came out in 2016
and it's called the Lim house Golem so I
feel like anybody that's into British
crime films or TV series that are set in
the late 19th century I think you'll
probably really dig this I really dug it
because I like that kind of stuff I mean
it's just it's a gorgeous looking movie
it has great acting performances has a
real twisty Miss history and has kind of
a really cool setting that you don't see
a lot um kind of set amid the world of
those kind of seedy back alley music
Halls that they used to have like back
in the day so the movie and excuse me
I'm a little bit sick so my voice is
kind of messed up so I may have like a
coughing fit at some point so I
apologize for that but um to the movie
is based on a novel which came out in
1994 and the novel is called Dan Leno
and the Lim housee Golem um and it's
written by Peter akroy now he's a
novelist obviously but he's probably
better known as a biographer and he's
written a lot of biographies of kind of
luminaries from that time from the
Victorian era and from the early 20th
century like he's written a biography of
Charles Dickens he wrote one of TS
Elliott Charlie Chaplain wilky Collins
so it's that kind of thing I had heard
his name before he's actually quite
famous um now interestingly well I
thought this was interesting but I
understand why they did it in the United
States the book did come out in the
United unit States um but the title of
the novel was changed from Dan loo and
the Lim house Golem to the trial of
Elizabeth cre and I'm guessing uh I
presume that that's because Americans
would probably have no idea who Dan loo
is no idea what a [__] Limehouse is
and no clue what a go what what a Golem
is like pretty much I I would think um
now the answers to those questions if
you don't know them Dan Leno was in fact
one of the most famous music hall
comedians in the world in the late 1800s
and was quite wealthy was made quite
Wealthy by his uh you know by him being
a performer uh lim housee was actually a
very poor and sketchy area of Victoria
in London kind of like White
Chapel and uh most people probably that
watch this show would probably know what
a Golem is but if you don't it's
actually a creature from Jewish folklore
that's essentially like a man made of
inorganic material usually clay that is
brought to life like with a magic spell
right and then kind of goes on a rampage
or somebody sends him out to like do
their dirty work or whatever so the
movie adaptation of the book Stars uh
Olivia Cook as Elizabeth cre who is
usually called
Lizzy and she's this young woman who
Rose from like horrible dire poverty to
become one of the most celebrated
performers in the music Halls of London
now I will note that um although
Elizabeth cre in this is a fictional
character she didn't really exist but
there are several of the other
characters who factor into the story
such as Dan loo uh Carl Marx and George
gissing were obviously real historical
people who lived in this time period so
they're kind of like I said woven into
the fictional
narrative now at the beginning of the
movie um which is actually kind of
largely told in flashback Lizzy gets
accused of poisoning her husband John
and it looks like she's probably going
to hang for it now
meanwhile while all of that is going on
there's also been a series of really
brutal like serial killings in the
limouse area um you know that are have
been carried out by someone that the
Press have started calling the Golem now
as I mentioned earlier in execution
these murders are somewhat close to you
know the crimes of Jack the Ripper but
most of this story is actually set I
think about eight years before those
actually happened because the Jack the
Ripper murders were 1888 and this is set
I believe in
1880 so the cops are kind of um feeling
the heat from the public uh because they
haven't been able to catch the
Golem so they bring in a somewhat
disgraced inspector uh named John
kildair to work on the case but also um
they bring him in in order to have
somebody to lay the blame on if they
can't end up solving the [__] you know
what I mean now killed a as it turns out
um has actually never worked a murder
case before even though he's you know
kind of getting on in age and it's also
made very obvious that he's been denied
a lot of career opportunities because of
rumors that he's gay they never tell you
if he is one with or the other but
everybody thinks he is and that doesn't
help uh the inspector by the way is
actually played by Bill Nye which I
think is I always pronounce his last
name wrong sorry about that um and but
he and he's great in this uh the role
was originally offered to Alan Rickman
actually uh but he had to back out
because of his declining health and um
you know sadly of course he died several
months before this movie came out I
believe he died at the beginning of 2016
and this movie came out like in Autumn
of 2016 so that was really sad I thought
but you know Bill nah does great in this
too but it was supposed to be alen
Rickman now not too long after kild a
arrives uh in Limehouse he comes across
a clue that the sort of hapless police
have so far
missed he finds this really
incriminating diary that seems to have
been written by the Golem um that kind
of goes into great detail about the
murders and about the philosophy behind
the murders and stuff this diary has
been scribbled into the
margins of a copy of Thomas D Quincy's
essay on murder considered as one of the
Fine Arts it's kind of like a satirical
uh work it's real you can read it um and
this copy of the book is held in the
reading room of the British
museum now from this inspector kildair
figures out that one of the four men who
signed into the reading room on the day
of the last entry in the diary has to be
the killer so he's narrowed it down to
four Dudes the four Dudes that were in
the reading room were the Music Hall
performer Dan loo uh the philosopher
Carl Marx uh the novelist George gissing
and a failed playright by the name of
John
cre now because kildair knows that Lizzy
cre is currently on trial for poison
poisoning John cre her husband and
because he's starting to suspect that
maybe John cre might have been the Golem
he goes to the prison to talk to Lizzie
about the case and from that point
forward the story kind of mostly jumps
back in time as she tells kildair her
story like it does kind of jump up to
the present day like you know where he's
still there and what's going on like in
the present day with her trial and
everything like that but it's largely
told him flashback while she's talking
about like what happened to
her sorry like I said my voice is so
terrible so Lizzy tells him that uh she
had a single mother who was very abusive
and that when Lizzie was a kid she
helped her mom they would sew and
deliver like sail cloths for a
living it's also pretty strongly implied
I don't even know if it's implied it's
pretty stated pretty uh outright that
she was like sexually abused by The Dock
Workers like when she made her
deliveries of the
sales now after her mom dies when she's
still quite young Lizzie decides she's
going to kind of follow her dream she
wants to be a star you know what I mean
so she goes to a music hall in Lim house
to kind of like find work now at first
she kind of gets picked up because she's
you know young and cute and everything
like that and they kind of put her to
work as like a gopher you know just kind
of like oh bring you know pies for all
the performers and fix this and do that
you know what I mean just your regular
kind of person
around so she so she does that
but not too long into this uh the
headliner and very famous comedian uh
Dan loo kind of takes a shine to her and
eventually kind of you know takes her
under his wing and like Becomes Her uh
Mentor I really like in this movie like
the way that the relationship between
Dan loo and Lizzy is kind of developed
like over the course of the story I mean
I feel like because when Lizzie arrives
at the um at the music to call she's
still like technically a child really
and I guess the story could have gone
maybe like a more salacious route or
something like that and had kind of you
know the very famous Dan like taking
advantage of her but they don't do that
and that was like kind of cool I thought
he actually ends up being like a real
true friend to her uh kind of like a big
brother type of figure and genuinely
wants to see her succeed and like help
her out in doing that um this
incidentally cuz I looked up the real
Dan loo cuz I didn't really know that
much about him and it seemed that the
real Dan loo was much like that as well
and I will say he had kind of a sad life
toward the end
because he was a real bad um alcoholic
and he started getting like uh you know
he would get drunk and get real violent
and then you know he would have to like
apologize and everything like that um
and he actually ended up dying like
quite young I think he was only 43 but
everybody that knew him said that he I
mean he was just like a beloved figure
they said he was extremely generous and
he was one of those guys that um was
really concerned with other performers
in the music halls and what they would
do after they retired or if they fell on
hard times or something so he actually
established uh several um Charities for
performers at music Halls like to help
them out like if they got into a jam or
whatever so I thought that was pretty
cool he sounded like a pretty cool uh
guy and they make him a cool guy in this
movie too so I thought that was kind of
cool now soon enough in the movie Dan um
recognizes Lizzy's like comedic Talent
right and so the two of them start
writing sketches together and then Lizzy
even starts performing and finds that
she's really into it she just loves the
attention she loves being in the
spotlight and as it goes on she starts
to become almost as famous as Dan is and
kind of really starts raking in the cash
uh satiric games says I love this movie
I did too I thought it was really great
and like I said I'm just really glad
that somebody recommended it because I
probably never would have gotten around
to it otherwise but it's like really
good this is I love movies like
this but um the thing about Lizzy though
and I guess a lot of actors and other
artistic people are like this she kind
of has greater Ambitions right she
doesn't want to be just some clown in
this tacky low rent musicall she wants
to be taken seriously as an actress and
she wants to be remembered like long
after she's gone she's like nobody
remembers the Court Jester or the clown
or anything like that they remember
people that had like serious roles you
know what I mean so she wants to be that
now it does seem that fate uh Smiles on
her when there's this journalist I think
he's a journalist or he writes for a
magazine or something like that uh named
John cre and he starts hanging around
the Music Hall and sort of like takes an
interest in her now it turns out that
John cre is also on the side a playright
and he thinks that Lizzy would be
absolutely perfect for the lead in the
very serious play that he's working on
which is called Misery Junction which I
thought was very funny I don't know
she's like yeah I want to be a serious
player I'm writing one called Misery
Junction you know what I mean should be
uh should be that's exactly what you
want it's a total bummer but yeah um so
this whole
situation of John cre taking an interest
in Lizzy uh kind of draws the eye of
another performer at the Music Hall
whose name is avaline uh she was
actually after John cre herself
and she gets super jealous and then she
starts to try and kind of like sabotage
like whatever it is that Lizzy's doing
like she does some pretty [__] [__]
I'm not going to
lie and also around this time there's a
series of strange tragedies uh that seem
to befall the company at this Music Hall
Once John cre starts hanging around you
know what I mean like there's a little
person actor who's one of the company
and he they were all at um dinner one
night and you know all been drinking and
stuff and he had like grabbed Lizzy's
thigh or her crotch or something like
that like under the
table and later on that night he
mysteriously falls down the stairs and
dies now because he was drunk everybody
just thought oh it was a terrible
accident and they don't really think
anything else about it however there's
also the matter of Uncle who is the guy
that owns the Music Hall and he ends up
essentially blackmailing Lizzy into like
posing naked for him and forcing her to
do like BDSM stuff with him like beat
him with sticks and stuff and he's like
oh I know all about you so you know I
mean so you can't tell anybody about
this or I'm going to like expose you or
whatever now when John cre finds out
about this going on he actually asked
Lizzy to marry him because he's like
well I'm going to make an honorable
woman out of you but then uh Uncle also
turns up dead only a couple days after
that so hm very
mysterious now Lizzie and John do end up
getting married but it's made crystal
clear that Lizzy only agreed to this
marriage because she wanted the role in
the play um and she basically refuses to
have sex with John right like on their
wedding night or whatever so after he
essentially rapes her on the wedding
night cuz she's like no I don't want and
he's like well you're my wife now so too
bad um so after that happens uh she
basically just knes out of her wely
duties altogether
and hires her rival avaline as a maid in
the household with the stipulation that
she will have sex with John so Lizzie
can be left to her own devices you know
what I mean she's like yeah here you go
[__] him I'm just gonna go do my own
[__] you know what I mean I don't want
to I just want a part in the play that's
all and I mean and the thing about it
too is that Lizzy uh she's the one with
all the money and she's the one that's
famous you know what I mean so she kind
of has all the power there's like a
power Dynamic and she seems to be only
using Jon as like a ticket out of the
music halls and into respectability
because she thinks he's going to go
somewhere like his play is going to be
good and she's going to get famous that
way like you know serious that way um
and so John knows this and he uh resents
like you know his wife's success
obviously so the relationship between
them is not great uh to say the least so
there's that whole dynamic going on
too now while Lizzy is cuz like I said
this is all flashback so Lizzie is
telling all this to inspector
kildair and as she tells her life story
essentially
kildair starts developing very
protective like fatherly feelings toward
Lizzie she says even during like uh the
course of the thing it's just like that
she brings out that protective Instinct
in men this which is why John cre wanted
to marry her like to protect her from
Uncle and you know and why Dan took her
under uh his wing and all this other
kind of stuff she's like yeah I bring
that out in people and she definitely
does bring It out and killed air who
like I said almost becomes like a father
to her and he just becomes so
distraught at the possibility that she
might be hanged for the poisoning that
he is just like bound and determined to
not let that happen now he has a theory
that John cre was the Golem the serial
killer and that Lizzie poisoned him
after she found out like what his true
nature was like she found out he was a
serial killer and she's like I'm going
to get rid of this [__] like
quietly you know what I mean but then
she kind of got caught now kildair
insists to her look if you tell this to
the authorities you know you'd probably
be seen as a hero and probably your
sentence would be commuted you wouldn't
be hanged and you know you would be like
everybody would be like really happy
about it because you got rid of a serial
killer you know go you so while that so
there's kind of like a sort of Race
Against Time element like toward the end
of the movie because killed a is like
desperately trying to prove this
hypothesis you know so the authorities
will buy it um before Lizzy goes to the
Gallows cuz like her time like her
execution is coming up like really
really fast so he has to kind of like
rush and like get all of the proof you
know before it
happens so I'm not going to spoil the
ending because this movie is not really
that old and I feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it um but as I mentioned uh
this is just a fantastic movie um you
know like I said it's a Victorian era
murder mystery has beautiful sets and
beautiful costumes um some like the
violence in it is actually pretty
Grizzly uh pretty shocking um the acting
performances are just great like across
the board uh the story is very
compelling and I really liked the really
interesting backdrop of these working
class performance halls and these kind
of old school pantomime kind of troops
and stuff like that it was like really
interesting there's not like a lot of
movies set in that uh you know in that
setting I guess um now the only
criticism I can give it is that I
guessed what the big twist was like a
significant amount of time before it was
revealed but to be honest that didn't
really bother me all that much um I was
kind of just I really just got into the
movie like the look of it and the story
and everything like that so it didn't
really bother me that I would kind of
like you know saw what was coming or
whatever so I'm going to say like if
you're real into British Murder
Mysteries and particularly if you love
anything to do with having to do with
like Jack the Ripper or other late 19th
century crime type stuff um I feel like
this would be right in your wheelhouse
and I'm really grateful that it was
recommended to me because like I said I
don't think I would have seen it
otherwise because it just kind of wasn't
on my radar and I had never heard about
it and it seems like I think it was
released over here but it didn't really
get much fanfare which is kind of a
shame because this is like a really
really good movie now as of this live
stream which is uh December 7th 20
23 um if you're in the United States you
can actually watch it for free on 2B and
I think Pluto TV might have it as well
although I could be wrong about that I
watched it on tuby um so as far as I
know it's still on there so if you want
to check it out you can watch it for
free and uh yeah that's pretty cool but
yeah um I guess that will do it I'm
going to wrap it up Danny Rowling just
got here so hey what's going on uh but
yeah because like I said I don't want to
talk too much because my throat is
killing me and uh I kind of want to give
it a w I couldn't talk at all this
morning actually like I woke up and I
was like you know what I mean because I
talked so much on the show last night I
guess that my voice just wasn't my voice
wasn't having it so I'm trying to kind
of like you know uh yeah Danny says
thirsty Thursday live streams or the
[__] yeah H I need to like get some more
booze maybe I just have water right now
I just had some iced coffee and then
then I was like man I just need some
water and
then I just need something to like make
this throat feel better I got cough
drops but I'm almost out so [__] but
yeah so like I said if anything that I
said sounded like it would be your thing
then you would probably love this I
really loved it I thought it was really
great and I can't I feel bad because I
looked earlier and I was like who was
that that recommended that and I thought
it was in I actually thought it was on
the YouTube comment somewhere but I
don't remember what video it was comment
on but so I went and looked today but I
couldn't [__] find it and I'm just
like God damn it it's like who
recommended that now I can't remember so
it's like so if you're watching this and
you were the one that recommended it
then drop it in the comments and thank
you because I really really liked this a
lot you you're right this absolutely is
in my wheelhouse but yeah so I'm going
to wrap this up and go rest my voice a
little bit so thanks you guys for
dropping by remember to click on that uh
audible link down in the description box
and I will see you guys again uh
tomorrow night for the Sidetrack show
when Tom will be here as well goodbye